c'est toujours de bonne guerre entre
majorité et opposition exprimée ces
désaccords
hier soir au conseil municipal de tours
après quelques minutes des changes où le
les membres des deux groupes
d'opposition tour nous rassemble et les
progressistes ont décidé de quitter la
table des élus pour rejoindre les rangs
du public et ne plus participer à la fin
du conseil
ambiance donc dans la salle du conseil
la raison un manque de transparence et
de considération à leur égard
hier c'est le sujet de l'urbanisme qui a
cristallisé les débats notamment d'un
document de cadrage pour les promoteurs
immobiliers 3700 logements sont en cours
de construction à tour avec de grands
aménagements à venir
les détails avec samuel colin il aura
fallu trois heures pour présenter le
projet d'urbanisme et les aménagements
prioritaires de l'espace public
certains dossiers sont dans la
continuité de l'ancienne majorité comme
le sanitas ou maryse bastié avec un
vaste programme de renouvellement urbain
déjà commencé et dans d'autres secteurs
comme le haut de la tranchée les bords
de loire où les halles de tours
l'actuel maire fait table rase tout est
à revoir
l'idée c'est de vraiment donner les
orientations de l'urbanisme pour notre
ville qui une urbaniste que l'on
souhaite plus résilient plus en
adéquation avec nos priorités qui sont
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique
et puis aussi dans la méthode ce que
l'on souhaite c'est vraiment instaurer
un travail avec la population des
habitants impliqués sur la zac des
casernes beaumont chauveau par exemple
ce mois-ci par tirage au sort des
riverains sont intégrés à un comité de
pilotage finalité choisir d'ici
septembre parmi cinq candidats
l'urbaniste chargé du projet mais
l'opposition elle dénonce un manque de
clarté et de communication de la
majorité
ça s'essouffle déjà des grands mots des
mots qu'on peut des mots personne ne
comprend mais à la fin quoi il ya deux
trois choses
c'est un maire qui plantent des arbres
qui met des pistes cyclables et qui veut
détruire la page en jaurès la place
centrale transformée d'ici deux à trois
ans pour l'arrivée de la ligne 2 du
tramway
une concertation avec les habitants doit
se tenir sur ce projet à partir de cet
été